bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7-8 sport
l'émission consacrée comme vous le savez
à l'actualité sportive dans le
département le sommaire de votre
émission
le sky rugby s'est imposé ce dimanche
sur son teint contre terre de france
conséquent ses idéaux et reste leader de
promotion d'honneur avec une neuvième
victoire en neuf matches disputés et
détail dans cette édition football coup
de projecteur aujourd'hui sur aurélien
collin le sportif originaire de
fontenay-le-fleury joue actuellement au
club d'orlando aux côtés de l'ancien
ballon d'or kaka
nous avons rencontré le défenseur star
de la major league soccer golf un joueur
originaire de montigny le bretonneux
pourrait devenir numéro 1 français dans
quelques années benjamin jahier 21 ans
vient de passer golfeur professionnel il
vient d'intégrer la 3e division
européenne porteraient à suivre et puis
l'essentiel de l'actualité sportive du
département nous parlons notamment du
titre de champion de france de marvin
petit une nouvelle victoire pour le sky
rugby les hommes de thomas payen se sont
imposés 32 à 13 à domicile contre terre
de france
conséquence et conséquence les yvelinois
conserve la première place du classement
devant clermont
le montage est signée romain respini une
véritable machine de guerre le style
rugby enregistré ce dimanche sur son
terrain sa neuvième victoire en neuf
matches disputés cette saison en
promotion d'honneur
l'ogre yvelinois dévorer terre de france
pourtant troisième du classement
le score est sans appel 32 à 13 en
première mi temps tous les murs nus on a
eu la possession du ballon donc on
marque sur sur deux actions de belles
actions à prendre un petit passage à
vide et en deuxième mi-temps à la fin du
match on a un peu la main sur le ballon
on joue chez eux des maul qui avance
bien on voulait avancer en marque
derrière c'est positif
c'est une équipe dure avec des joueurs
durs qui descendent d'honneur donc ont
l'habitude à un niveau d'engagement
supplémentaire
donc ça a été malgré ce corps qui est un
peu large à la fin un match très serré
assez rude
grâce à cette victoire le sky rugby
terminent la phase aller en tête du
classement le club compte deux points
d'avancé sur l'une des meilleures
équipes de la poule
3 clairement la montée plus que jamais
envisageable pour les yvelinois api
présidente comme on dit oui non je peux
pas faut pas rêver mieux parce que il ya
deux ans je pleurais derrière les
poteaux parce qu'on comprenait des
premiers des scores très sévère hélas
cette année mais c'est tout le contraire
c'est nous sommes invaincus
voilà contrat rempli 18 matches gagnés
sur 11 9 en réserve 9 en première fois
peut pas être arrivé
notre objectif c'est la montée donc on
va tout faire pour même sans ces cas
notre division n'y a que deux clubs qui
m'ont surtout l'île de france donc c'est
très exigeant
on a eu la chance sur les phases aller
de recevoir le premier le deuxième et le
troisième
donc aux phases retour fallait va
falloir aller gagner chez eux et savary
êtes très compliqué le sky répondre à la
compétition le 10 janvier à l'extérieur
contre l'entente trier les mureaux mais
avant de se replonger dans le quotidien
du championnat place aux fêtes de fin
d'année après le rugby on passe au
football coup de projecteur sur le
joueur professionnel aurélien collin
aurélien collin joueur originaire de
fontaine fleurie est à 29 ans l'un des
meilleurs défenseurs centraux de major
league soccer
la première division américaine sportif
évolue actuellement à orlando avec le
club avec le ballon d'or brésilien kaka
nous l'avons rencontré nous sommes avec
le footballeur aurélien collin le joueur
d'orlando chez lui à paris bonjour
aurélien alors vous jouez actuellement à
orlando je le disais précédemment mais
en major league soccer
mais avant de parler de votre club
orlando nous allons tout d'abord revenir
sur votre parcours vous êtes originaire
de fonte et le fleury vous avez un
parcours assez atypique
vous avez joué à sedan amiens en espagne
à majorque en grèce au pays de galles au
portugal avant de rejoindre la mls
expliquez-nous un petit peu ce parcours
un peu atypique pour pourquoi ces
parcours atypique en fait au final et
j'ai commencé en france
cent deux formations au stade de reims
ensuite je suis parti à sedan à amiens
où j'ai signé mon premier contrat
stagiaire pro la france n'a pas donné
une chance en professionnel je pensais
que à 50 qu'une chance qu'une chance
même pas une opportunité pour jouer en
pro donc j'ai décidé 13e de quitter la
france
maréchal et un meilleur que ça s'est
bien passé mais je n'étais pas encore
dans le groupe pro 100 % et j'ai eu
cette opportunité en écosse pour jouer
en premier league
donc je suis parti et ça s'est super
bien passé après après quelques mois des
pro et mac le président donc plus de
salaire j'étais obligé de chercher un
autre club je suis parti en grèce tout
le monde connaît la situation en grèce
où les salaires et sont pas très payer
donc j'étais obligé encore de chercher
un autre club portugal la même histoire
et d'après arrive cette opportunité qui
tombe du ciel des états unis et c'est
pas trop déstabilisant pour un jeune
joueur parce qu'au final vous étiez
jeune à l'époque jeune après 29 ans
aujourd'hui vous visitiez je n'avais pas
versée ouais c'était c'était difficile
après j'ai jamais perdu cette confiance
en moi et beaucoup d'expérience beaucoup
de voyages et grâce à ça j'ai appris à
parler toutes les langues sauf le grec
et voilà et puis après ça fait qui je
suis aujourd'hui et grâce à ça j'ai
cette opportunité extraordinaire qui est
d'être arrivée en mls
donc la mls c'est pas du tout un choix
par défaut pour vous non après c'était
une opportunité à saisir une opportunité
j'ai essayé beaucoup de choses ans
en europe et bas j'avais un manque de
stabilité on arrive dans des clubs où il
y avait des installations qui étaient
vraiment pas professionnel et donc en
gros la perfection des états unis qui
est professionnel à tous les niveaux
quand c'est arrivé j'ai même pas hésité
une seconde
donc vous êtes arrivé à kansas city
c'est là que tout a démarré en fait au
final
ouais quand sa city donc j'arrive donc
les réponses hors mercato d'hiver 2010
les entraîneurs de de kansas ils sont
venus me voir je vais particulière
contre porto et nacional madère où
j'avais fait des très bons matches et
sont venus monde si vous avez supervisé
avant pouvez bien sûr bien sûr et ils
sont venus et m'ont offert le contrat et
vous savez à la règle de la fifa quand
vous avez trois mois de retard salaire
vous pouvez casser le contrat ce qui
c'est ce qui m'est arrivé
après je suis parti aux états unis le
rêve américain commencer et vous avez
pris le numéro 78 en référence aux il y
aura là exactement quand diana fleury
fait je sais versailles aux quais une
grande grande partie de ma vie donc en
hommage aux yvelines où et j'ai pris 78
et comment vous trouvez le niveau de la
mls
du coup vous qui avez un petit peu
voyagé un peu partout
le niveau est plutôt correct bacon en
comparant
mes équipes de la mls et toutes les
équipes que j'ai fait en europe elle
était meilleure
quant à city on était meilleur qu'eux au
portugal que en écosse
après c'est sûr en espagne sommes
meilleurs que j'ai joués il y avait des
très grands joueurs à majorque diallo
tristane ira gaza avait alors moins y
avait des très gros jam après bien sûr
le niveau de mayer qui était meilleure
mais non un niveau technique physique
surtout physique extraordinaire
après niveau tactique c'est ça a évolué
chaque année et donc c'est moi je peux
pas comparer avec avec l'europe puisque
chaque championnat ses caractéristiques
mais un bon niveau dans lequel j'ai
progressé j'ai travaillé donc la saison
dernière vous avez quitté quant à city
pour orlando pourquoi ce choix c'était
c'était un choix on va dire que vous
avez peut-être fait le tout vous avez
gagné plusieurs trophées notamment et
kansas city notamment le trophée de
devenir meilleur joueur de la finale
c'était peut-être la fin d'un cycle
il fallait relancer un peu votre envie
de jouer pour le foot dans la mls où ça
s'est fait comme ça pour voter en fin de
contrat c'est en fin de contrat après la
mls c'est la règle des lois il ya plein
de loi no juste en fin contrat
mais malgré ça si le club donc kansas et
ils m'ont ferait un nouveau contrat à
plus de 5%
c'est comme si activé une cinquième
année donc j'étais en fin de contrat
mais ce n'est pas gratuit et fin d'un
cycle oui je pense que kansas city c'est
les équipes à l'art auxerre enfin
saint-etienne con con énorme un énorme
pouvoir niveau de la formation mais
après pour aller plus haut il faut
partir de ce club et orlando qui était
une nouvelle franchise mais avec de
grosses grosses ambitions
j'ai eu cette opportunité donc je suis
parti à orlando et ça a été une très
bonne initiative parce que roland doha
c'est un gros club pas américain sein du
club mondial qu'on fait venir kaka et
condé gros gros gros moyens donc je suis
très content de la descente j'ai pris
justement quels cas le brésilien joue
avec un ballon d'or voilà c'est ça rêve
c'est un rêve c'est magnifique
une personne extraordinaire humble très
professionnel et après techniquement bas
meilleur que tout le monde donc ça fait
progresser et vous avez des liens avec
lui enfin ou
vous êtes coéquipiers coéquipiers même
ami peut-être en dehors du temps non
amine ans après on est tous et de
chrétien croyant
ensuite chacun a son cercle d'amis on on
se respecte on est coéquipiers mais
après on dort on n'est pas mais pas plus
que ça a mis non vous êtes collègues on
est qu'elle a exactement de travail et
votre jeu finalement vous êtes défenseur
ou les spécialistes vous disent assez
rugueux dur sur l'homme
vous êtes d'accord avec eux ouais je
suis un défenseur au sens propre du
terme
après j'aime beaucoup le ballon donc
quand on peut jouer je joue quand on
peut pas jouer ce jeu-là dégage mais
j'aime beaucoup de contacts et un vrai
un vrai défenseur central et vous prenez
quelques cartons aussi de temps en temps
je jeu j'ai mûri première année chez
arriver j'en avais 13 buts et le enfin
le meilleur je vais pas dire le meilleur
mais le joueur qui avait le plus de
cartons cette année en 2011 et là
maintenant j'ai pris que j'ai pris deux
rouges et seulement un jaune donc on
voit la progression depuis 2011
et vous avez aussi un excellent jeu de
tête vous avez marqué une quinzaine de
buts en quatre saisons avec kansas city
un petit peu plus un petit peu moins
cette année pour l'instant c'est sale et
seulement deux buts seulement deux buts
après je marque beaucoup c'est en pleurs
et pendant les matches clés voilà
exactement la saison c'est tout le temps
2 3 4 mais bon c'est sûr au niveau
défensif
mon goût mon point fort c'est le jeu de
tête mais j'essaye quand je peux mettre
un petit coup de tête sur un corner ça
fait plaisir et vous êtes coincés là
comme l'un des meilleurs défenseurs de
la ligue principalement grâce à ce jeu
de tête en cire voilà c'est possible et
du coup ce palmarès s'est construite
petit à petit vous avez été élu meilleur
joueur de la finale en 2013
vous avez gagné aussi une coupe aussi à
kansas city en 2012 c'est ça si je me
trompe à votre palmarès finalement a
pris du temps à se garnir mais il garnit
petit à petit exactement
tous deux travaillent beaucoup de
sacrifices et ça a payé à mes 25 ans et
donc c'est pour ça que petit à petit moi
ma carrière là quand elle a débuté plus
tard que la plupart des joueurs de
football
donc j'ai 29 ans aujourd'hui encore très
jeune à l'intérieur à l'extérieur et
donc je suis parti là bas en espérant un
jour peut-être revenir au meilleur
niveau en europe
ou alors faire ma carrière 100 % aux
etats-unis
là je suis marié avec une femme du
venezuela et donc les rapports sont
faits très proche où venait cela peut
être un jour représenter la sélection du
venezuela et et j'ai créé mon petit
monde aux états unis donc en vivant le
l'american dream
mais en même temps on ne jamais oublier
mais mes racines et aimons 78 et donc
voilà après on verra ce que le futur me
réserve donc pas forcément une sélection
française j'ai eu des contacts avec
didier deschamps ont pas du tout rien du
tout j'ai quitté la france avait 19 ans
ça fait dix ans et là aujourd'hui même
j'étais beaucoup plus rapproché à
cheveux pour les états unis et enfin
quand je suis parti en 2011 mon coaching
pareil la sélection des états unis après
au niveau du coeur les états unis et moi
en bas au niveau des racines des
cultures c'est un petit peu différent et
là maintenant ça fait cinq ans que que
le venezuela c'est ma deuxième maison
donc on verra ce qui se passera en fait
y'a donc pas contact non plus avec le
venezuela pour l'instant si les contacts
ces montagnes de contact beaucoup de
contacts et
et donc donc on verra et vous avez été
reçu par à la maison blanche et barack
obama vous avez un petit peu chambré sur
sur votre costume je crois ce jour là
ouais il parlait des choses des
accomplissements des des joueurs en
dehors du football et il apparaît ma
marque de vêtements et de la manière
avec laquelle il était habillé avec mon
costard c'était marrant une petite vanne
et moi ça fait beaucoup de bruit ici en
france c'est beaucoup de buzz en france
resté bas c'était un honneur de
rencontrer barack obama il est très
charismatique et après on peut attendre
des accords avec sa politique mais
c'était une très belle expérience que 1
français est passé aux états unis
en tout cas c'est un monde que vous êtes
pleinement aussi intégrer aussi
maintenant aux états unis entre voilà
les spécialistes qui qui a pas de parler
de vous barack obama le lettre le
trophée votre marque de vêtements aussi
donc vous êtes vraiment pleinement
télémaintenance et comme dit tout à
l'heure c'est finalement le rêve
américain
ouais bien sûr ça fait cinq ans de viol
aux états unis donc il ya une part de
moi qui est américaine après j'ai des
goûts - la gastronomie et beaucoup enfin
beaucoup de choses états unis ce ne me
ressemble pas trop apprécié les états
unis qui m'ont donné cette opportunité
au niveau du football donc on a fait un
grand merci à ce pays on va parler de
l'avenir maintenant
orlando bloom est signé pour cette
saison phrase est signée simon dernière
orlando est ce que vous comptez y rester
encore quelques années ou es ce que vous
avez encore je sais pas deux objectifs
près de revenir en europe par exemple
mon objectif à moi je suis parti aux
états unis pour trouver une stabilité et
un encadrement très professionnel
les américains sont très professionnels
perfectionniste et donc c'était
exactement ce que je recherchais même un
but d installation ah oui c'est un autre
et même au niveau du suivi à tous les
niveaux et donc là maintenant je suis au
au pic de ma carrière 29 30 31 pour un
défenseur central
et j'ai encore un an de contrat donc on
va voir moi je ne prends pas la tête je
travaille à fond c'est de faire le
meilleur match que je peux et c'est une
opportunité qui vient on verra
l'ambiance d'un stade européen ça vous
donne
envie boisseau final l'ambiance aux
états unis est quand même à kansas était
sympathique kansas city on avait un
stade high tech 1 comme on dit avec des
choses qui est extraordinaire à
l'intérieur du stade et à l'extérieur
20000 personnes soldats faut pour 75
matchs de suite non au niveau des
ambiances et là on nous enfume 40000 de
moyenne le pr nation et à 62 milles à
orlando donc non je n'envie rien à
l'europe
après c'est sûr si on compare avec le
real madrid-barcelone liverpool chelsea
les mercredis européens bien sûr mais
faut rester au niveau donc un club moyen
de deux premières divisions non j'ai
rien à envier et mais après on c'est sûr
que je suis parti là-bas pour travailler
et revenir plus fort si un jour je
remets prêts aux états unis j'ai
vraiment un statut très bien donc on va
ainsi l'opportunité vient et c'est c'est
quelque chose que je recherche depuis je
suis tout petit comme une bonne libyen
un club de première ligue de bundesliga
c'est sûr que je réfléchirai
mais sinon très bien là où je suis très
concentré avec un nouveau club avec
beaucoup de moyens et une ambition
énorme donc la liant c'est possible oui
bien sûr 20 sur l'alignement la france
la moitié de mon coeur elle est
française donc ça serait un rêve et
est-ce qu'il ya un club qui vous fait
rêver en particulier en france ça moi je
suis à paris bons caf un mois à fontenay
soixante dix huit c'est paris ça nous
fait rêver depuis que je suis tout petit
depuis tout petit avec fontenay avec fc
versailles match contre paris
saint-germain qu'aujourd'hui par le
paris saint germain c'est le real madrid
donc pour aller jouer là bas faux je
sais que j'aurai un premier stade enfin
d'aller dans un club un petit peu plus
au niveau du statut un petit peu plus le
psg et après si je suis très performant
aller au psg mais non bien sûr jouer au
psg c'est le rêve de tout parisien
et puis on est très fiers enfin que ça
fait longtemps que la france n'est pas
un club qui représentait la manoeuvre
aux états unis tout le monde parle du
psg mais ça fait plaisir donc une
association ou un aurélien collin thiago
silva
peut-être l'année prochaine au psg
pourquoi pas beaucoup de respect thiago
silva pour moi c'est un c est le
meilleur défenseur au monde donc
beaucoup de respect donc jouer à ses
côtés sa peau est très sympathique
merci aurélien collin merci à vous en
continuant à vous suivre évidemment la
saison prochaine en mls et dans sept
huit sports on en parlera régulièrement
merci beaucoup rien que l'inversé
le parcours de la course cycliste paris
nice a été dévoilée ce jeudi à l'hôtel
du département de versailles les
yvelines accueilleront le prologue de la
compétition à conflans sainte of sainte
honorine et la petite commune de congrès
sur vogue organisera le départ de la
première étape mais ray loisel pour les
images c'est une tradition pour la
septième année consécutive la course
cycliste paris nice organisé du 6 au 13
mars s'élancera depuis les yvelines
la ville de conflans sainte honorine a
été choisi pour le prologue de cette
soixante quatorzième édition
elle succède à maurepas au programme une
difficulté le sentier des laveuses une
cote de 200 m une petite difficulté est
assez courte qu'on aurait dû classé hors
catégorie du tour de france mais qui va
en arrêter plus d'un qui va provoquer d
d d écart à l'arrivée et ensuite un
parcours beaucoup plus plat pour aller
chercher la ligne d'arrivée donc un beau
décor d'ensemble je pense qu'on va avoir
d'excellentes images ça donne un peu le
ton de la semaine de paris-nice de
pourcentage raid cours mais raide et
puis un parcours où il vraiment
séduisant qui est fait pour tous les
types de coureurs donc vivement le
printemps une deuxième vie sera à
l'honneur sur ce paris-nice 2016 condé
sur vos grands 1159 habitants a été
sélectionnée pour accueillir la première
étape de la compétition
une première pour ce village situé près
de rambouillet ça va faire drôle de voir
les bus des équipes dans ce village
toute cette animation mais non mais
c'est ça le cyclisme aujourd'hui on
on se déplace partout le stade c'est le
stade il va partout où il va dans les
villes de 50 habitants s'ils voyagent en
irak et donc on est sûr c'est que c'est
parfait c'est parfait pour nous le tracé
programmés dans les deux villes
yvelinoise a séduit les coureurs
présents ce jeudi à l'hôtel du
département de versailles pour la
présentation officielle
une plaie complètement je serai encore
pour hors jeu
je pense que je serais venu sur ce
paris-nice pourquoi pas je vais
peut-être reprendre le vélo mais non non
il me plaît énormément et je pense qu'on
va avoir du beau spectacle c'est surtout
ça qui est important
une centaine de coureurs est attendu sur
paris-nice parmi les têtes d'affiché on
retrouvera les stars françaises romain
bardet tony gallopin l'australien richie
porte et l'espagnol alberto contador
vainqueur du tour de france
on continue ce magazine par de la boxe
l'élan courtois marvin petit 24 ans est
devenu champion de france des poids
légers à ce jeudi au cirque d'hiver de
paris
le boxeur a licencié au bc saint quentin
en yvelines et dans quoi remporter la
victoire aux points contre le
montpelliérain sylvain chapelle les
juges l'ont donné vainqueur à
l'unanimité pour vous parler de cette
belle victoire nous recevons sur ce
plateau marine pâtiront soir bonsoir
alors vous allez bien récupérer votre
combat ça va je compte bien récupérer
maintenant alors vous avez gagné aux
points est ce que vous attendiez un
combat si difficile je savais que
c'était c'était quelqu'un de dur ça
c'était sûr que c'était un combat que
calais durée après moi j'ai eu une
blessure une fracture au nez donc j'ai
pas voulu le dire à personne mais tant
qu'il voulait ma nuit les combats et
donc de rentrer votre entraîneur vous
l'a aligné le combat voulait ma nuit les
combats et j'ai fait une très grosse
préparation pour ça et j'ai pas vous
l'annulez combat qu'en gt gt jusqu'au
bout et c'était un combat qui était très
médiatisée avec beaucoup d'attentes
est ce que finalement ça vous a parle si
peu stressé parce que vous avez aussi un
chaos
peut-être avant le combat vous allez
finir finalement terminé au point
est-ce que vous n'étiez pas trop stressé
la disant si c'était un peu stressant
parce qu'ils avaient beaucoup beaucoup
de linge est passé à 00h01
moi j'étais bien j'étais dans ma tête
j'étais bien j'étais vraiment bien
j'étais prêt j'étais un peu craintif
pour m'avoir blessure fracture du nez
que j'ai eu c'est un peu ça qui m'a
empêché de boxer plus que mais sinon au
niveau physique gt gt très bien j'ai
fait une bonne préparation n'ont été pas
mis en place en fait c'est sainté j'ai
là vous avez été offensif alors du coup
j'ai non j'étais en face il faut en fait
au niveau du premier round site et pas
une stratégie que je devais mettre en
place ma stratégie devait mettre en
place je voulais lui rentrer dedans et
pas lâcher en fait et ça a été tout
avait été mis en place avec tanguy tout
a été mis en place avec tanguy
en tout cas on voit que le public vous a
soutenu sur ce combat oui c'était encore
plusieurs centaines
ouais comment expliquez vous justement
7,7
cette effervescence autour de vous on
dit que vous êtes le peut-être le boxeur
qui attire peut-être le plus de monde en
salle comment l'expliquez vous disons
une grande famille déjà on a une très
grande famille après chez nous chez les
gens du voyage chez les gitans
c'est du bouche à oreille et sont très
fiers de duchesneau quoi et vous êtes un
showman aussi notamment votre entrée et
ai été très remarquée j'aime donner du
spectacle jean et sens là et cela pour
voir du spectacle les gens y payant pour
pouvoir du spectacle et voir un combat
sont pas ils sont pas là que pour peu
pour payer vivant le combat phare du
chauffe-eau fin du spectacle comme comme
à l'étranger comme à los angeles las
vegas comme
est-il de meiser et donc vous aimez le
spectacle j'aime le spectacle j'adore et
vous préparez peut-être je sais pas l'an
prochain un prochain show que d'être
votre chien combat il sera quand son
prochain combat ce bal a pas pour le
moment j'ai pas j'ai pas de gp2 encore
j'attends j'attends la date
prochainement peut-être au défendre ma
ceinture de champion de france ou une
autre une autre opportunité on verra
lacombe à las vegas c'est possible
prochainement on propose pourquoi pas et
vous avez traversé une période quand
même assez délicate avec votre titre
perdu contre yvan mendy en juin 2014
est ce que finalement c'est une
renaissance cette victoire à ses
intrigues renaissance et ça c'est un
très grand plaisir et vous affichez
désormais un bilan de 17 victoires un
nul et une défaite
du coup maintenant plus rien ne peut
vous arrêter vous avez une défaite c'est
fini la suède veut plus des fêtes c'est
fini pour venir me battre foireux de
mettre ko que je me relève plus du tout
c'est j'irai jusqu'au bout jusqu'à la
mort merci marvin petit et c'était un
paysage bourg soir sur ce plateau on
suivra avec attention la suite de votre
carrière est bien sûr beaucoup de
réussite en vous souhaite beaucoup de
réussite pour prochain combat on passe
maintenant à l'euro 2016 on referme ce
magazine donc par du football la
sélection nationale d'irlande a choisi
verset comme camp de base pour l'euro
2016 une compétition qui je vous le
rappelle sera organisée du 10 juin au 10
juillet en france les verts emmenés par
le joueur du et les galaxies à robbie
keane seront logés au trianon palace de
versailles et s'entraîneront sur les
terrains municipaux du stade montbron on
écoute le maire de la commune françois
de mazières était au micro de patrick
jacques de dixmude
on est ravis de recevoir les irlandais à
versailles pour l'euro et on leur
souhaite d'être heureux à versailles
mais j'espère que ça la france qu'il
gagnera tout seul l'équipe d'irlande
affrontera dans le groupe e l'équipe
d'italie la belgique et la suède
c'est la fin de cette fuite sport merci
l'avoir subi on se retrouve le lundi 4
janvier pour un nouveau magazine très
belle soirée sur tv fil 78